على مدار جلسات الاستماع هذه
، أثبتت الأدلة أن هناك
خطة متعددة الأجزاء بقيادة الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لقلب
ثقل الأدلة المقدمة حتى الآن لانتخابات عام 2020 والتي
أظهرت لنا أن السبب الرئيسي في
6 يناير كان رجل واحد دونالد ترامب.
الذي تبعه الكثيرون لم يكن أي من هذا
سيحدث لولا وجوده ، فقد كان
منخرطًا شخصيًا وبشكل جوهري في
كل ذلك ، فقد علم جهاز الخدمة السرية
والوكالات الأخرى باحتمال وقوع
أعمال عنف قبل وقت طويل من
خطاب الرئيس في الجزء الناقص
بالرغم من هذا البيت الأبيض المؤكد و
شهد شهود الخدمة السرية سابقًا
أنهم لم يتلقوا أي
معلومات استخباراتية حول العنف الذي
كان من المحتمل أن يهدد أيًا من
الحماة في 6 يناير ، بما في ذلك
نائب الرئيس ، تشير الأدلة بقوة
إلى أن هذه الشهادة ليست
ذات مصداقية
بشكل خاص ، حيث اعترف بأن جو بايدن
سيتولى منصب الرئيس هنا
بعض الأمثلة على أننا في
المنزل القديم هناك مناقشة  حسنًا
، يقول الرئيس أعتقد أنه كان من الممكن أن
يكون بومبيو ، لكنه يقول كلمات تشير إلى
أننا فقدنا ، علمنا أننا بحاجة إلى ترك هذه
المسألة تذهب إلى الرجل التالي
دون مساءلة.
شاهد الأدلة اليوم ، يرجى النظر في مكان وجود
أمتنا في تاريخها ، وفكر
فيما إذا كان بإمكاننا البقاء على قيد الحياة لمدة 246 عامًا أخرى